housekeeping first
if the fire alarm is activated please
vacate the offices via the stairs please
do not use the lifts assembling holy
Square on the green officers will assist
you and advise when it's deemed safe to
return to the chamber
would everyone present please ensure
that their mobile phones are turned to
silent and that they are not used to
make or receive phone calls whilst the
meeting is in progress
please switch off or turn to sign your
mobiles and do not make the calls while
this meeting is going on
please note this meeting is being live
streamed for members of the public the
meeting will also be recorded and will
be subsequently broadcast on the
internet
I have to ask if anyone intends to film
the meeting but there are no members of
the public HR so
we will move straight on
offices in attendance Colin Carmichael
the chief executive Samira Khan interim
head of legal and monitoring officers
monitoring officer and Charles will be
taking on our minutes
I have received apologies from councilor
Alban who is being substituted by
councilor scoby
item two is Declarations of interest
does anyone have any interest to declare
in the items of business on the agenda
for this meeting
no Charles
item three minutes of the previous
meeting to approve the minutes of the
meeting of the general purpose committee
held on the 4th of November 2022 and a
copy of which is attached to the agenda
pack
please can I have a proposal and
seconder propose David Saunders
seconded councilor Bob bayford
do members agree
item four
Senior Management restructure to
introduce this item counts is Colleen
Carmichael chief executive thank you
thank you leader certainly not counselor
no sorry
um thank you thank you very much
um
are going to assume you've read the
report I'll just pick out highlights for
you
um it goes on a bit I agree but I
thought I'd do that rather than keep it
short see what I mean because I think
this is pretty important subject it's
probably better for you to see all of
the reasoning behind
all the thinking than not
um at the moment the delegation that
exists in thanet which I have to say I
find surprising is that the chief
executive is able to take decisions on
the senior management structure in terms
of directors and heads of service
not the position that I've come across
in previous councils and it seems that I
mean even if you are only considered to
be the governing body of the council you
ought to be in a position of agreeing
the structure for the senior level
underneath the post of chief executive
so I'm working on the basis although
technically you don't have to agree the
structure I'm asking you to at least
endorse it and I will take it as your
formal approval
um it's also the case that the chief
executive I gather appoints to directors
and heads of service and I'm suggesting
in this that
councilors should appoint to the post of
chief executive and directors and the
chief attack should appoint to head to
service
so that in many ways summarizes the the
report
um the reasoning behind what I'm putting
forward to is set out mainly in in
paragraph two
um at the moment there are temporary
Arrangements in place
with
senior staff covering slightly weird
combinations of activities
um my favorite is that Matt sandema's
finance manager is not only the acting
head of Finance but also the acting head
of operations never come across anything
like that before I entirely understand
why it's been done I'm not in any way
criticizing it but the sooner we get out
of it and back to some form of normality
the better
the other main reason from my point of
view is that
um about eight or nine posts are
unfilled because everybody is waiting
for the structure to be formally
approved and there's clearly no point
appointing to any vacant posts until
everybody knows people particularly who
might apply from outside know what the
structure is that they're joining and
that it has some logic behind it and as
a result of that although I think people
are you know people are working really
hard the people who are doing the cover
are working incredibly hard and and
doing their very best there is a limit
to what people can do and there are many
projects that the council wants to
deliver which to be honest we're
scrabbling at the really important
issues such as the leveling up funds all
of those sorts of issues are being
progressed but at the expense of issues
such as what do we do with this building
where there's just not enough capacity
at the moment to deal with that not
enough thinking space I know probably
people like me have said this to you for
years but but genuinely it is a bit of a
problem so sooner that's fixed the
better
um so that's one main reason the second
which we'll all know about are the
section 24 reports and the independent
monitoring officer report which clearly
argued in favor of a review of the
structure a little bit to do with the HR
function but I think within the context
of reviewing the structure and I think
it's not been reviewed for some time so
now is definitely the time to do it
um from paragraph 2.5 I talk a bit about
the recruitment process and the
suggestion that as soon as we can
effectively we set up what I'm calling
an appointment subcommittee of this
committee which would be politically
balanced and would be able to take
decisions on the appointment of the
chief executive and the directors of the
council through a formal interview and
recruitment process
in the future that is
um in paragraph four I go through the
principles behind what I've been putting
forward this absolutely isn't rocket
science and I've actually quite
deliberately gone for what I suppose you
might call a fairly traditional local
government structure primarily because I
don't think anybody will want the thing
to be torn up and put back together
again in the USA's time whatever the
position about the future of the chief
executive position
what you want that individual to be able
to do I would suggest would be to be
appointed and be comfortable with the
structure they've inherited so that the
rest of the staff have a good two to
three years ahead of them where they can
assume that they are in post doing the
things that they're appointed to do with
enough time to get on with these major
projects all of which take some time so
that's been an important thing from my
point of view
so I talked about Support Services
that's effectively within a corporate
services department the service delivery
of which there is a lot because thanet
has an in-house waste and recycling
service employing around 250 people
that's a very big thing which most
councils don't have so I think you need
two departments to manage the direct
Service delivery and I do think it's
really important the chief executive has
direct control over what I'd call the
direction of the council which is partly
to do but I hate the word brand but it
is the brand of the council what how we
appear to the outside world the
communications that we use to describe
ourselves
of the digital agenda which we're
trickling in at the early stages of here
in thanet but we do need to get our
Collective heads around that because the
ability to access services online is now
so universally accepted expected outside
the council in the private sector the
sooner we can get on we're doing a lot
of that within the council the better
and obviously the policy team climate
change and so on being a point being
positioned in the center reporting to
the chief executive is pretty important
I would say
um job titles
um are worried about this because I
don't really want to confuse issues
everybody's probably got used to the
corporate director and service director
titles but that is quite unusual
um and I did consult and I've consulted
twice as you will see
um in the report and the vast majority
of people wanted to return to director
and head of service one or two people to
be honest who are currently called
service directors who made the perfectly
valid point that it might appear to the
outside world to be a demotion and I get
that and I did think about assistant
directors and directors but actually the
vast majority of people were fairly
clear that going back to director and
head of service made a lot of sense and
so that's the proposal I'm making
um I've dealt with the HR function which
was a specific thing of the uh the
independent monitoring officer and
effectively created a post of head of HR
managing the AHL function reporting to
the director of corporate services which
I think positions the HR function in a
much more positive way
um in paragraph
um five I've talked about the
consultation process very happy to
answer any questions on that I was quite
pleased with the number of replies I got
they absolutely weren't all from the
people at the senior level quite a few
people at a relatively junior level gave
me some really interesting ideas many of
which I've actually Incorporated in
weather functions actually report to
people who've done a job for years who
basically said I've always wanted to say
this but
how about if I report it to that person
instead of that person and sometimes the
overall picture you know didn't allow
that but quite a lot of the time
um it did
um so in paragraph six I just summarized
the main proposals proposing to create
four departments
um and I have set out there the very
specific posts and the functions
underneath all of the posts I will
undoubtedly have missed a function
somewhere or put it slightly incorrectly
or named it incorrectly so in the
recommendations as a proposal to
delegate to be in consultation with a
leader any slight changes I need to make
and occasionally you know things will
come up as you're implementing these
things where you think oh that function
actually would be better somewhere else
but the general overall shape is very
much as I've set out here paragraph
eight I've talked about the
implementation
process the position at the moment is
that as soon as you've approved this
today formally the
senior managers who are currently in
post have their posts deleted they
become at risk of redundancy I've
actually technically already put them at
risk of redundancy very sadly the day
before Christmas I think I did I don't
know why this always happens just before
Christmas why do restructures always do
that I think they've all taken it in
their stride but the sooner we can give
them some certainty the better so if you
approve the recommendations today I have
set up internal interviews for me to
conduct next week with all of the staff
whose posts are being deleted so that
hopefully by the end of next week they
will have been appointed if you approve
the recommendations to some of the new
posts we then go on to go through the
process of competitive recruitment for
the remaining posts I think it's really
important we do competitive recruitment
as opposed to keeping things internal no
harm at all in a few people coming in
from outside bringing new ideas and new
skills with them but also giving the
opportunity for internal staff you have
some really good stuff here in thanet I
mean I've been really impressed since
I've been here at the commitment and
energy and positivity positive nature I
mean given what Council has been going
through for the last year or two it's
really good to see and there are some
people at reasonably Junior levels who
should have a chance of being promoted
into the more senior posts otherwise we
might lose them but they should do that
against competition if they get the
position then they've got a mandate
um having been selected against the
outside world which I think would be the
good thing to do and I've been very
clear about that and staff in do to
accept that so there's process for
implementation the slotting and ring
fencing process again if you'd like me
to I'm happy to go through that and then
finally there's a structure chart and
once we've formally agreed the structure
I'll confirm that chart with names
against the post that people are
appointed to and if it's not too
confusing I'll list the functions
underneath all of the posts a fairly
consistent message I've had from
counselors is you don't know who does
what so the sooner we can actually get a
structure together where you do know who
does what the better it will be and that
shouldn't take too long
and that's it leader thank you very much
thank you chief executive uh members
questions uh councilor Everett
um yeah thanks for the report Colin um
uh I think it's excellent
um and I don't have any problem with any
of the principles in it and you did
share
um some of the outlines of where you
were going with it why you were putting
it together which I appreciated
um and obviously we all as counselors
have to work with it it's just not for
the current Administration so that's all
good and I think it's good that we can
have some consensus around it
um
I think the issue of um
um councilors appointing the director
level I absolutely agree with you I
think it's slightly confused by the fact
that Council appoints the 151 officer
and the monitoring officer and since
those post holders have tended to be at
director level
it almost wasn't an issue really in
terms of those two posts now obviously
you're proposing something slightly
different here which is which is fine as
understood
um but I think that does go back here a
long while I don't think it was a recent
development or something that was
inserted in the system in the last few
years I think this was the case going
back to the 2011-15 council as far as I
know
um one of the things I wondered about is
you know we have and hopefully we're not
going to be in the position in the
future of having lots of temporary
appointments but to what extent would
the temporary appointments
um be discussed with members and through
this structure and the other thing
really is about
um
it's great that you put these
recommendations in front of us but
clearly GP doesn't have the authority to
change the scheme of Delegation
um so what you're saying is you'll go by
what GP says today which is fine are
these changes in terms of how
appointments are made going to be
incorporated into the Constitution and
are they going to go through a proper
constitutional process in order for that
to happen because I think part of the
IMO recommendations was a review of The
Constitution
um so I don't know where we are with
that and and how that's all going to
flow through and just finally a comment
I think about the appointment panel it's
a great idea having a politically
balanced appointment panel but it can
get quite clunky even so if you've got
four parties and you've got one party
which is significantly larger than the
others you're already down the road
probably of having five or six people
um and obviously political
proportionality isn't always going to
mean that every party gets
representation and we don't know what
the situation is going to be after the
election nonetheless there can be
challenges in that as always sorry
thanks
yeah
um on the last Point
um when I was pointed in Canterbury the
appointment committee was seven
councilors which was pretty terrifying
um two labor two conservative three
liberal Democrats and the vote was 4-3
interestingly but spread around so I was
quite happy with that but um no I mean I
I I agree it's clunky but to be honest
honest candidates at this kind of level
need to expect this and most candidates
would expect councilors to be on the
panel it is usual
um and I don't think they'd be put off
and to be honest to anybody who is put
off by facing a council Council a panel
of six let's say shouldn't really be
appointed to the job being a bit
simplistic about it I don't think they
should
um the 151 admon monitoring off so yeah
the 151 record in the recommendations is
attached to one of the director posts
and said there wouldn't be a problem
with that you're right Council has to
appoint the monitoring officer so it's
perfectly possible thinking about it
that the correct thing to do we need to
have a conversation with Samira because
of course samira's interim and once the
structure is completed we'll then need
to take a view about what we do about
the post that Samira is covering but
um I think the formal position is that
Council has to formally approve the
allocation of the role of monitoring
officer so I mean either we can make it
simple and say that the councilor panel
appoints the post of head of service and
democracy and monitoring officer or the
chief executive appoints to that post
and then Council formally approves the
monitoring officer being
applied to that post if you see what I
mean just need to think about it
personally I'm very happy with it being
extended to counselors you know why not
and why make it overly complicated
thinking about it in terms of the change
the Constitution Samira to do because
you're managing that
yeah thank you
um basically two update members
um following the um fundamental
appointment of engage with an external
company to look at the Constitution
review
um we've just started the process
literally just before Christmas so it's
work in progress
um they will be coming with a report in
terms of the format the time scales and
exactly what we need to change in light
of the recommendation and I'm intending
to bring you that to the cwp committee
towards the end of February I believe we
haven't got a date yet but it will be a
report going to that and then obviously
it'll go to council thereafter so it's
in progress it it will take a little
while because it's not just one
recommendation there's quite a few of
them the scheme of Delegation this
officer member protocol and there's
other title little things that needs to
be mandated in there so we are working
towards it collectively so I have
engaged an external company to look at
that
thank you and uh just more broadly of
course that falls within the section 24
and the IMO recommendations And
discussing with the leader very recently
the
the benefit of reporting to council
properly through cabinet
about how much hopefully all of the
recommendations have been completed
before the local election so I think
this Council has gone through the Hoops
in terms of those reports you should see
what's been done about them I'm hoping
we're fairly close now to
the end of the review of birth or five
which was one of the the recommendations
that was being made so we should be able
to report on that too so we're we're
close to that you mentioned uh members
being involved in in temporary
appointments didn't quite understand
that which temporary appointments did
you mean no I was just saying that um
well we've got a temporary
um an illegal really policy I hope so
what I'm saying is where
if temporary appointments were made to
the director posts yeah and obviously
there'll be need to be although I think
they fall outside the scope of what
you've suggested temporary head of
service from time to time but I mean if
you had to make a temp if there was a
need for a temporary appointment to a
director post is that something that you
would envisage being discussed by
members or yeah because I would yes
um whether it's temporal permanence I
think if members
have the
have the uh what's the duties the right
word to appoint the post-director that
should apply whether it's temporal
permanent I think whether you'd want a
full appointment subcommittee meeting to
interview candidates depends on how
rapidly you need somebody
um you could do it by consultation by
email or something of this but I think
having it endorsed even if it's a
temporary position would be the right
thing to do
thank you um I I think I can
um understand where Council Everett's
coming from because I think there were
quite a few appointments to this Council
of interim senior officers statutory
officers that actually didn't Pro that
actually weren't processed through any
any type of member involvement so I
think that's probably where you're
coming from Rick and absolutely agree I
mean I could never understand although
it might be a statutory an interim
statutory officer they are still at a
statutory officer that and if they end
up staying for a long period of time
then members should certainly have
involvement with the selection of of
that so I and I think that's a a bit of
a gap in the system that we need to
close so that's refreshing to hear hear
that next to speaker councilor Austin
thank you leader and thank you Colin for
this I think it's excellent and I'm
really pleased to see various ways in
which it brings us more in line with the
way that the majority of councils do
things names and everything and member
involvement I think it's particularly
important having had a reputation as
being an officer-led Council in the past
and we've addressed many of those issues
that going into the local elections we
can say to voters
here is a a proposal that will involve
members in appointing the senior
officers because it makes no more sense
to say uh as I've heard people say we
have no jurisdiction over that or that's
not our remit with regard to senior
officers than it is to say you know we
um you know why have we got no remitting
sorting out cleansing Services because
Mark greeney is a professional and he
can do it better than we can it seems to
me that that that's there's a
misunderstanding there about about roles
and delegation and it's really important
particularly at the moment coming up to
elections that we make it really clear
that we are the council we are in charge
in whoever our successes are will be in
charge
um I've just got a couple of questions
the first one was about what you
envisaged the time scales might be and
the second one has gone totally out of
my head so if you were down to the first
one I might remember the second thank
you that's me all the time
um yeah the time scale I mean as soon as
possible I would say although
so the choices are effectively the first
of March but that feels a wee bit quick
but but actually if
the slotting and ring fencing
appointments are made next week which
I'm hoping to be able to do
than actually the first of March
isn't too far away the first of April
however would help in terms of accounts
but that might leave people hanging on
for some time so it's
um I'm tempted by the first of March I
have to say just to get it done I would
still need people to continue with some
of the acting Arrangements because there
will be a number of posts that are
vacant which will need to be covered so
for example
um
nobody
is either in a position to be slotted or
ring fenced into the head of operations
which I'm now calling the head of
cleansing
and Matt is covering that and I would
want Matt to continue to cover it until
it was filled
through some sort of competitive
recruitment so we'll still need to do
some of the acting pending appointments
being made I mean I'd quite like again
who's subject to agreeing this having
done the slotting or infancing
appointments next week to advertise the
other posts in February
and then to be recruiting to them
probably in March and just getting it
done as quickly as possible so you know
first of March makes some sense that's
probably what I would go Finance
colleagues would rather it was April
Simon a bit of a conversation about that
the other thing was if I may and that
was just you and I have had a little
conversation I think on email about uh
involvement of the broader generality of
members and you mentioned the
possibility of maybe doing something at
a members briefing about your thinking
around this so that it could be shared
more widely with counselors have you got
any further with that thing happy to do
that
um obviously once that's all it's all
done we've got people appointed and I
forgot to answer an earlier question
which I think was to do with reporting
some of this to council
um and yes the changes to terms of
reference of this committee the creation
of the appointment subcommittee will
need to be formally approved by Council
because those are changes to the
Constitution
um to be fair to Samira I bounce the
mirror because it's been a it's it was a
very confidential process if you like
Paul Samira got about two hours to look
at the the legality of some of these
issues and we had a debate about what
was to be reported to council and what
wasn't we don't think the structure
needs to be formally approved by Council
but the creation of an appointment
subcommittee does
and the changes to the terms of
reference I'm not here on the 9th of
February it's almost told the leader I
was away in February
um so but I will be back on the 23rd
evening so I'm it would be helpful from
my point of view to have all this
reported to the 23rd of February Council
and then we could get it all formally
changed
councilor Byford
yeah thank you chairman
um I can't remember how long ago it was
now but we used to have a system here
where uh for pointing the chief
executive there was a panel that
actually brought a short list usually
three people and then those three
actually presented to council and
Council made the choice that seems to me
that he raised her eyebrows
as well but I mean I I believe that it
gave a lot more buy-in to the
appointment with it being done that way
and I can certainly remember
um being a member of a group for all
that time
um that you know our leader would have
been on the sort of shortlisting and
would then come back and then their very
best to convince us without seeing
anybody which one we should pick
um but we didn't have to pick that one
but I mean I it does seem to me that
um you know the full Council for that
appointment involved in some way would
make some kind of sense and the other
thing it's incredibly nitpicky thing but
it does prove I've read the report
Under head of coastal and public realm
you've got open spaces and Under head of
cleansing Services you've got street
cleaning but my understanding is that
we're now recruiting operatives who are
flexible to work across both the
discipline so it seems a bit strange
that they they're in different under
different service heads
okay on your first point I've heard the
city of London does that
and I've also spoken to a candidate who
had to go through it once
and the person was a gibbering wreck by
the end of it
um
I mean you can do it you absolutely you
can do it um there is there are some
councils that require Council to endorse
the recommendation of the appointment
subcommittee or whatever they're called
before the person is appointed that's
quite common actually and you can either
you know as Council delegate everything
including the choice to the appointment
subcommittee or Council can reserve the
appointment of the chief executive in
particular to themselves but they'd have
to do that on the back of their
recommendation from the appointment sub
it just feels to me like an
managing an interview process
from 56 councilors might be a slightly
tricky thing to do
but in the end you know just thinking it
through in the end this is a politically
taken appointment
and you might well be right and there's
more buying very happy to have a
conversation about about that as an
alternative you know my instinct was to
delegate it to an appointment
subcommittee
which is a bit what's the word Cozier
and easier for people to to deal with
but you can do it the other way
yeah I mean but the small point that
does seem to me that there is this
potential I think it's cancer ever it
raised that you know you could get a
certain balance of members here that
meant if you politically balance that
committee you you would lose
representation from some sections of the
membership completely
um and some involvement at full Council
would at least enable that to happen and
I don't know if it's possible but I mean
it seems to me you could always almost
get a situation where the controlling
group actually held sway on that
appointments committee even though they
might not have been the majority in
Council
I think they wouldn't would they though
if it was politically balanced
yeah yeah I suppose it does yeah
but there are a lot of smaller parties
that might not get a representation on
that selection panel
um then you could land up with the
controlling group having a
disproportionate say even though they
weren't the majority
yeah I think
maybe not
maybe I haven't thought that through
properly
very very happy maybe I'm just ready to
seeing potential chief executive sweat a
bit
no harm in that
on the Open Spaces issue
um yeah I mean where to put Open Spaces
was actually one of the
Hot Topics in the second round of
consultation and I'd say about half of
the officers who replied thought that
what you suggested was the right thing
to do which effectively would have put
Open Spaces into cleansing
and the and the the basis of that again
was exactly what you were saying which
was
everybody that works in these areas are
effectively blue-collar workers and
you can switch people from Open Spaces
to street cleaning and vice versa if
you've got shortages
and I mean I can see the the advantage
of that
um
in the end I kind of got to the Moon a
number of other people took this view
that open spaces you should go by
functions on whether they connect to
other functions rather than work on the
basis of the kind of kind of worker that
operates in a particular in particular
areas so you know open space is being
connected to the kind of work we do on
beaches and and the coastal areas
made some sense
I would confess so I was you know as a
very close run thing this one you could
have gone the other way
so
Council Everett
yeah I was under the impression that the
social officers had to be
um appointed by full Council certainly
the monitoring officer and the and the
151 officer so presumably the head of
paid service does as well
um uh in my experience I was called
governing bodies where we've had
interview panels and we've interviewed
for the head teacher and I don't know
whether this is the law or it was just
uh the way that we were set up to act
but certainly we would interview and
choose a candidate and then we would
take the recommendation to the full
governing body admittedly the full
governing body didn't have 56 members
um but we would take it and then and
then the full governing body would agree
it so I'm not sure what we're discussing
if I mean I appreciate chief executive
and the head paid service aren't
absolutely necessarily the same person
but they're very likely to be the same
person here so wouldn't we be taking it
to full Council anyway
yeah he was although I think Council
bayford was talking about interviewing
by full Council
um which I I'm not entirely sure is is
good but four Council formally
appointing no were you not I'm sorry
well not not in the true sense of the
word I mean they'd already would have
been interviewed by some kind of I can't
remember what commission it was or how
they arrived at it but they would do
that and they would bring you a short
list and you know there were there was
the opportunity for a limb very limited
number of questions that's all but
primarily it was presentation by that
and as I say
um sort of information given because
each group had in those days had a
representative on this selection
committee so that that person could
report back on what they thought and
what we should be looking for and so on
um but it I I mean I just felt it gave a
better buy in that so
well maybe we could combine the two
points and you're quite right I think
they had to pay service clearly does
have to be appointed by Council I think
Council have to agree that I would be
head of the paid service before I
started I think the council did
um that's simply however saying the
council agrees that a named individual
should be should hold that statutory
role but if you combined it with the
possibility of some form of panel
politically balanced panel getting the
numbers down to two or three people and
offering those choices to council there
might be another way of doing it
um I mean my suggestion would be if you
if you're comfortable with this that you
agree once
in here and that we have the
conversation with the next Council as
soon as possible as soon as it's
selected about which way they would
prefer to go
very happy to make a change then and and
have accordingly
um members I intend to just
um for the point of correctness just run
through the the the nine
um
recommendations but I also having gone
through it closely myself
I would like to move an amendment to
item seven
which I'm following that conversation
I've actually amended it slightly from
my original proposal Amendment so I
think Charles
I would move the amendment now and get
that through and then go through and
then read the amended through on the
last one right okay so members
all right so um item seven
um
of the recommendations
so
it's for the X for this exercise only to
delegate to the chief executive the
responsibility of recommending
appointments to vacant posts of director
at the company competitive recruitment
stage to this committee for formal
approval I would like to propose that we
amend that to move that the appointments
of directors and chief executive made by
the newly formed appointment
subcommittee
um which would then go on to be formally
agreed by full Council
so
um members have any
any thoughts on that
councilor bayford
only thinking that if after
today effectively
um you need people at director level
um it may may be the chief executive for
pointing those
interims you you need that in here don't
you
so so what I was suggesting the
recommendations but you know there are
lots of different ways of skinning in
this particular cat so I'm not I'm not
worried about changing it is is really
to get the appointment process into the
new structure carried out as quickly as
possible I was suggesting that I do all
the appointments but ask this committee
to meet and formally endorse the
recommendation I think what leaders
proposing is that the appointment
subcommittee would be created as soon as
possible is that correct and that the
director of appointments which would be
effectively the director of place and
the director of environment
would be appointed by that subcommittee
and then reported to council are you
saying yeah right
the director of corporate services is
going to be ring fenced to Chris
Blondell so that would probably subject
to the interview be filled as part of
next week's processes but the other two
directors would be vacant
but I mean would you not need
some of your newly appointed heads of
service one or two of those need to step
up to fill those director roles in the
very short term
and if that's the case wouldn't it be
easier that you do that because you only
do it from the people that you've got
there already
um and that the appointment of the
directors when it actually comes to it
then this committee gets involved or
that appointments committee gets
involved
I was trying to avoid it being too
complicated and really I was thinking I
would just keep the current temporary
Arrangements in place so for example at
the moment Bob Porter is temporarily
covering director of place just leave
that be until the post is filled by the
method the leader's talking about
cancer over it yeah and I think to
constitute the appointment subcommittee
you've got to go through the
Constitutional process and bring that to
council to be agreed because otherwise
the committee doesn't exist so I think
we're then pushing down to the end of
February before you appoint the before
you can appoint the subcommittee so I'm
not I don't think this is a sensible
Way Forward if I'm honest not for any
other reason I just think we need to get
on with things
um
I don't see a way around that if you're
going to go through a proper
constitutional process
I think maybe right okay the bit I might
cause a confusion with is that I'm I'm
concerned
um at the two at the Three director
levels
um obviously I would like them the
subcommittee or even the GPC to have
some sort of oversight on that because
these are
um
director of corporate service which is
um obviously a ring fence position the
director of environment and director of
place technically are
new position so it'll either be
um
existing
[Music]
officers that
apply for it or external so I just was
my thoughts are that those positions
won't be advertised until
probably March we could do it in
February we could do it in February but
the applicants are coming by March by
which time we could have formed the
recruitment
process it's just that I wanted members
to be involved because they are two
really high level positions within the
council I just wanted us to be involved
at that stage I mean I'm quite happy to
to actually
um for the for the chief executive to do
it and that's originally where our
thoughts were coming from
but at some point it needs to come
through either GPC
I'll then move on to council as we're
saying
for these positions I mean I'm easy
either way it's just that I felt that I
just that that this would then bring
more members into the actual
into the process at an earlier stage but
I'm obviously up for up for debate on
this I mean I can see what you're saying
as well but I think the timing would fit
in into it I'm not sure whether we can
get
I assume we could get it into the
council meeting at the end of February
for the formation of the
um recruitment committee
you've got committee you've got Council
on the 9th of February
I know Colleen's not around then but
there's nothing to stop the subcommittee
beans
yes budget here
yeah I mean I I don't know whether that
budget on the night whether the full
Council does it have to be exclusively
canceled but certainly we could bring it
to the 23rd so um I think that will be
plenty of time to form it and it's
really just to to put it through an
extra process and it's only for the
director level of which there will only
be two positions plus the future for the
I mean we've got to bring it in anyway
because it has to be in there for
obviously the recruitment of the chief
executive going forward so I thought if
we bring it in sooner rather than later
then technically what are new positions
in the new structure then if it could be
up and running then it would only click
into the into the process
house roster
as I said before I'm all for more member
involvements much more involved in such
a practically can although I'm a little
scared by councilor bayford's uh
suggestion but but yes I'm I'm with that
as long as it can be managed in the
practically in the time scale that we're
talking about because we don't want to
be hanging about and it's not fair to
staff to keep them hanging around
councilor bayford
at the risk of doing this to death
chairman I still think there's an issue
that if chief executive is going to put
these people into their slotted
positions in the next couple of weeks
that at the same time really if then as
just mentioned him we could say if he
still wanted Bob Porter as the temporary
director of place
for that to happen Chief needs to have
the authority to do that without this
committee getting involved
so it's a sort of two-stage thing I'm
just thinking that you know if the place
is going to run smoothly then Chief
Niche is about to put his temporary he
might want to appoint a temporary
director of environment for instance out
of one of those people and I just think
that
that needs to be done without member
involvement
as long as member involvement is there
for the permanent positions
those are really it's not for the
interim
process it is for
when we go live with the new structure
so does that sum it up I think maybe
I've caused a bit of confusion here but
um I mean there has to be a point of at
which time this this
um appointment committee is formed and
when it becomes live
so it's whether or not it becomes live
after the chief has done all that he
needs to do
or whether we do it at a stage where the
chief has done everything that he needs
to do and then we then we cut in the
appointments committee I think my
intention is to cut in the appointments
committee is for when we actually start
the recruitment process for the director
level but um I mean how we word that
that that's my that's that's what I'm
trying to do as opposed to everything
being done and then we say right okay
we've done everything we need to do with
the new structure now the appointments
committee come in but everyone's already
in place so you know
it's it's where we where it lies with
that but I will um
I will uh I mean if someone wants to
amend the amendment then uh that's fine
but
Chief exactly maybe um I mean are we on
the same page here of I actually
confused the uh so I I think
tell me if I'm wrong but I think what
you're suggesting is that councilors
through this appointment subcommittee
should be involved in appointing to the
director of environment and director of
place which otherwise in the
recommendation I set out here I would do
yeah
um I don't think it holds it up if you
wanted to do that because all we need to
do is to get the subcommittee in place
if you're comfortable as a subcommittee
for example with me doing some short
listing and presenting you with three or
four or five whatever candidates for you
to interview I don't hold it up
particularly all we need to do is get it
in place by the time
Council meets on the 23rd of February so
that you can formally set a subcommittee
up and have it in place picking up your
point counselor Bay for to be useful to
explicitly exclude the temporary acting
Arrangements because otherwise we will
get trapped into all sorts of process
but if we would say something along the
lines Charles about delegating
to me under seven
the
responsibility of taking decisions about
temporary cover Arrangements pending the
new structure being put into place
and to
picking up in eight
recommending to counsel the creation of
politically balanced appointment
subcommittee take out the words of
Municipal year and say as soon as
possible
with terms of reference to a point to
oversee the process of appointment then
that would include the new directors
coming along so we just take out the
words the municipal year if you're
comfortable I could have a work with
Charles and Samira and just get the
wording right I think I think we know
what you're trying to achieve though
which is that counselors are are
given the role of appointing to the
director's place and environment which I
think picks up people pointing Council
Austin yeah
I'm okay with that I'm fine with that
counts forever so just on a question of
timing then we're gonna we're gonna need
to have
um a constitutional review working party
meeting and a standards meeting
before the papers are required for the
23rd of February in order to propose the
Constitutional changes aren't we because
that's the way they have to be done
not a Witcher in the Dory at the moment
let's go through standards does it
do we think that's possible because if
it's not we need to say so now
should be all right
before the 23rd yeah
councilor Byford
I was just questioning why it has to go
through standards I mean constitutional
working party I can understand but I
don't understand what has to go on
standard I think that's what's in the
Constitution well yeah yeah I know but I
don't see why it does
what
would be good if it didn't
Samira can you note that that we want to
amend the Constitution
I need to check with this because I
think you're right I need to double
check with this the cwp or whether it's
the standards committee but can I come
back and confirm that I'm pretty sure
it's standard but let me just double
check the Constitution before we
go
yeah
but we haven't got any dates we've got
dates for standard haven't we
no it's not
foreign
well I know in the previous
um constitutional review we had I mean
that was called quite late doors so I
mean we are quite used to constitutional
quite hard working party quite used to
being called in quite quickly so and the
standards followed our last one quite
quickly afterwards I think it was about
members allowances or
uh something like that I can't remember
now but um we I
I think it can be called within within a
couple of weeks and then the other the
standards can follow straight after so I
think we should better fit it in between
now we've got 23rd we've got
four weeks haven't we so we should be
able to do it
well I'm not moaning but I sit on the CW
football piece so it's um it is WP so
that's another meeting I've got to go to
so yeah I mean I don't have a problem
and I think that
if that's the Constitution that's what
we've got to do but uh so to be clear on
my Amendment
um we are saying
the wording on item seven is amended to
um the appointment of directors and
chief executive
be made by the newly formed appointment
subcommittee and in this instance
referring specifically to the two
outstanding
director roles
and that will then formally be agreed by
Council
you want them approved by accounts
director pose
because I'm because because it includes
the chief executive appointment then it
has to go to the council as well so full
Council so
it
we can't can we the director roles going
forward do we want to see the director
roles bearing in mind that that usually
includes a statutory officer to go be
approved by full Council so in order to
to save any confusion it might be at
that level which is the director level
that and above which is the chief exec
go to full Council just for
um approve final approval following the
recommendations of
the appointments committee
sorry cancer I just feel we're sort of
trying to do the work of the
Constitutional review working party now
and I I think that you know we're only
making
um we're only having a discussion we're
not because we're not making any
decisions here anyway so perhaps that
what that leads is further consideration
by crwp will refer it for further
consideration and then you can put your
proposal there
because otherwise we're trying to
resolve an issue that we're actually
we're not in a position to resolve
councilor Byford yeah let's just kind of
says and as far as today is concerned
um I mean I thought the proposal was
that
um we'd effectively delegate the chief
exec to work with Charles to work on
wording for seven and eight given that
he understands what it is we're trying
to do
which I I think is to allow councilors
to appoint to the post of director of
place directive environment I think we
can tweak the wording to make that
happen
no problem
I think the problem sorry to in terms of
having directors confirmed by council is
the amount of time that might take you
might just fall with an interview date a
week or so after Council and then
everybody's got to wait three or four
weeks until the next meeting of council
to get their appointment confirmed it's
not great really
I mean I personally haven't thought an
appointment subcommittee appointing
directors
and having the power to do that would be
fine I absolutely take the point about
the chief executive post being confirmed
by Council that seems sensible but
people are many people will be used to
that and probably expect it so I think
holding directors up for a month or so
may not be
good thing to do
Okay so
I always draw that proposal and replace
it with that
item seven will stay as is
but I propose that the
that particular part of the process is
referred for future processes referred
to the Constitutional review working
party to decide its exact
wording and process
so for this particular exercise item
seven will stand
foreign
so would you like to make a counter
proposal then and then I can
[Music]
um
okay so have you got that um
right so I have a proposer to amend
seven and eight
see how nicely I've manipulated it into
your proposal
Council Everett is second
so
that is seven and eight
[Music]
um
I think we need to go just for the sake
of clarity refer back to what members
being asked to so we've agreed that
so we need to also agree the items one
two three four five six and nine
what one to nine okay
and there's been well it's been seconded
by cancer Everett so
um I think members like to has been
proposed and seconded I'd like to see a
show of hands for this particular item
of if we are in agreement with that
that is unanimous Charles
thank you members um it's been an
interesting meeting and uh that
concludes the business for today
thank you I declare the meeting closed
at
4 28.